hello everybody i'm jesse waters along
with juan williams
jillian turner greg gutfeld and dagen
mcdowell
it's five o'clock in new york city and
this is the five
the consequences of rolling back common
sense border policies are blowing up in
joe biden's face
his incompetence is creating catastrophe
like we've never seen before
and now donald trump's tearing into the
current president with a scathing
statement
trump slamming biden's disastrous
leadership for creating a
spiraling tsunami of migrants and
unaccompanied kids showing up at the
border
but the white house says they won't be
taking any advice
we don't take our advice or counsel from
former president trump on immigration
policy which was
not only inhumane but ineffective
over the last four years we're going to
chart our own path forward and that
includes treating children with humanity
and respect and ensuring they're safe
when they cross our borders
and republicans in congress have had
enough
the democrats and joe biden they want
more illegal immigrants crossing our
border
as soon as joe biden took office he
ripped up agreements with mexico the
the very agreements that were stopping
this border crisis the narrative that
the president is putting out that
is seemingly inviting people to come and
the numbers are starting to show it
so this is a huge national security
issue that the buy administration
is saying is only a challenge no this is
a crisis this is a disaster
and it's a disaster of their own making
maybe the white house should try
listening things getting so bad the
administration is reportedly
looking at a military base in virginia
to house
unaccompanied migrant children and axios
is reporting the cdc is letting those
child migrant facilities fill
to a hundred percent capacity despite
coveted concerns but hey we can't call
it a crisis
just yet i guess all right so greg
gutfeld joe biden is
transferring kids in cages to a military
base
named after a confederate general in a
state
governed by a democrat who wore
blackface you can't make this stuff
up and these facilities are going to go
to 100 capacity
but our restaurants can't so uh
but what i learned today which was
amazing is that the migrants are
actually ignoring
advertisements telling them not to come
here so only democrats would think that
a wall
doesn't work but ads do that's like
saying
okay okay folks uh don't put locks on
your doors just put a sign that says
please don't come into our house and
take all of our stuff this is
again dems do not see the value of
friction
and disincentivizing behavior they say
walls don't work
but obstacles by nature obstruct you
don't have to even be a strong
wall to to slow down progress but they
don't understand that
so now they got a problem and they can't
they can't take any advice from trump
because he's evil
even though his advice would actually
save their butts
yeah i think they're so arrogant digging
they can't admit a lot of the policies
and deals that trump cut
with the central american nations and
mexico
helped stem this flow of unaccompanied
minors
but biden created this crisis and i
don't think he has a solution do you
uh no because this is actually biden and
co's immigration policy their policy is
come on in
borders open bigger government we're
going to create this vast welfare state
for you
and the bigger the government is the
more power we have and oh we'll make you
a citizen and then you can vote blue and
it's going to be
deep deep azure from sea to shining sea
uh i'll one-up you the restaurant 100
capacity so the migrant child facilities
can go to 100
cramming those migrant children in there
but our kids in this country
can't get back to school because that's
not because
that's not safe so joe biden and co
have created this perverse incentive for
children and their families to put their
lives at risk or
rather smugglers and traffickers to put
those very children at risk
but you won't hear them call it a crisis
or chaos it's
it's a challenge and that's one thing
about democrats and then
fascists and others who have
fascist-like tendencies
they're not gonna it's the language they
try to control the language it speaks to
two things the craven way
that the democrats govern but also their
true opinion
of the american people they think that
we're all stupid
that if they call it a challenge that
we'll just sit there we don't know
whether to like scratch our watch or
wind our ass we'll just sit there and
nod and act like
uh that what they're saying is true and
then you're going to have the media pick
up the language
that the democrats are using and all is
well and good while
children are suffering at the border or
at fort lee and virginia potentially
jillian i want to play some sound of a
border sheriff
pretty upset about the fact that they
dropped wall construction and then the
cartels
can funnel right through listen
when president biden rescinded the
emergency order on the southwest border
it stopped resources and stopped
construction on our border
as a result of that one area where the
fence is not complete we get five or six
groups a day coming across there
uh it's opened up the border it opened
up the mess
okay to come in this country
and that's just common sense right well
certainly pausing or if not halting
forever construction on that southern
border wall was one of the first things
president biden did in the white house
when upon becoming president what i
don't understand here
though jesse is that every four years
the u.s government
has this like spate of collective
amnesia where they have to wipe
everything that came before
pretend they're starting from scratch on
the immigration issue and that they've
got to come up with this
entire new slate of policies to solve
these really big
intractable problems but the reality is
that the vast majority of americans
have held very consistent views on the
immigration issue
for many years upwards of a decade in
poll
after poll after poll from republicans
democrats and everything between about
70 percent of the american people
want stricter enforcement of the
existing immigration laws the laws that
are on the books
coupled with some kind of a pathway to
legal
citizenship or a process for pursuing
legal citizenship
for would-be immigrants to this country
i i will say that what we're seeing now
this fight over emergency versus crisis
versus challenge versus
obstacle is just political theater i
don't think anything
we're talking about now really matters
one of the
somebody who did have a smart new
proposal that i've seen in this go
around
of this same old argument on the
merry-go-round is senator romney who
said
one thing we're not doing that we really
need to be doing is focusing more on
domestic
issues and focusing on businesses he
proposed this idea that businesses who
want to employ
undocumented immigrants have to have a
special visa in order
to do so that would solve a lot more
problems than haggling over every
additional half mile of the border wall
yeah i don't have a problem with
seasonal workers coming in and
and doing that kind of labor but it's
just the the flow
right now is unsustainable one and
they're predicting it's going to get
even worse
in the next three to four months what's
baden going to do about it
you know i think that we should look at
it in terms of what jillian was just
saying
as something that comes you know it
doesn't matter who's in office
republican or democrat
it's the busiest border in the world we
get surges we have some problems this
problem it could be a commerce problem
an immigration problem
of course we have the whole issue of who
we grant amnesty to in terms of
you know crises down and south south of
the border
uh but again the whole thing should be
congress
acting congress should act so you know
jillian was saying hey you know the
american people republican and democrat
they say hey look we want border
security
but we also want a pathway to
citizenship especially when dealing
with the young people the dreamers you
know in 2013 we came close to
comprehensive immigration reform on a
bipartisan basis i think we got to 63
votes in the senate it passed in the
house
today we're farther away from any
compromise because we're so
politically polarized and you know just
listening i say people
use this immigration issue to demonize
the other side and say the other side
you know biden doesn't want to let
people and biden's the one guys i said
to you sometime this week
who stood on a democratic primary stage
and said he was not for decriminalizing
illegal crossings of the border so keep
that in mind
that joe biden stood on the same stage
and said he's for giving illegal
immigrants
free health care too no look okay i tell
you what
i'm just saying to you using your voice
jesse
my voice across partisan lines we should
be saying to the congress
let's solve this problem let's have some
compromise if republicans want to focus
on border security democrats want to
focus on
resolving the issues for not separating
families and for people who are here
including the dreamers
that's the basis for a deal stop with
the cheap rhetoric
look but i got to respond here because
whenever there is a push
for comprehensive immigration reform the
word comprehensive
is only only really the new word for
amnesty
the people on the right actually are
willing no
let me finish the right are always
willing to
compromise and listen because all they
want is
a process something that isn't a
free-for-all that's what republicans
like
the dems never consider people who abide
by the law
when it comes to guns you guys target
the lawful
when it comes to student loans you don't
care about the people that actually paid
their loans
and for those who immigrate lawfully and
do it the right way
too bad too bad just go to the border if
you actually respected process
we might trust you but you don't because
as dagon says
you keep changing the language you'll
crap on a dish
and tell us it's a brownie it's not the
case
it's not the case greg i mean obviously
you know a large percentage of this
comes from
visa overstays and the like commerce
we have to work on this issue sincerely
there's no
we when it comes to democrats that's
what i'm saying
i don't trust the comments when it comes
to republicans
we don't trust congress they're you're
in congress
we gotta go we gotta go joe proposed
an immigration deal and it's doa because
they had no border enforcements